précédemment dans l'amour n'est pas dans
le pré vous avez vu le clash de la
quiche fallait pas que ça ait quelques
brises on and on parle et inti celui du
bouquet de fleurs et laurence à la ferme
auxquels j'ai pensé que je découvre et
celui du karaoke
dans l'épisode de ce soir nathalie
laurence et françois découvre de karaoké
enfin surtout françois je voyais pas
comme ça mon des pieds d'écran je
connaissais pas ces inscrits la chanson
à mesure qu'elle est chantée en fait
parce que c'est bien ça correspond bien
aux chansons que les gens chantent fait
logique bref ça va être parfait pour
défendre nos trois loulous de karaoke
nathalie samson première et attention
que personne ne la dérange
[Musique]
mais mon dieu qu'est ce qui lui a pris
de parler sans clash cette affaire
surtout que c'est au tour de laurence de
chant c'était qui m'obsède jour et nuit
[Musique]
roy pas là
on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge qui de
laurence ou de nathalie arrivera à
titiller le berlingot de francs soit la
réponse la semaine prochaine dans
l'amour n'est pas dans ok pardon je me
tais
on est en effet d'autres d'irak a
cartonné serré au karaoké hier s'est pas
passé que ça on est obligé de vous
montrer la prestation de laurence
franchement c est non moi je me serais
retourné dans ce virus voilà mais chez
moi j'ai kiffé voilà l aller à fond
dedans regardez
[Musique]
ça danse ça chante bien jeter à l'eau
et
[Musique]
c'est
la meilleure phase je chante bien
je suis pas tu vois j'ai pas les
oreilles qui saignent tout ça ça passe
crème alors on a découvert également
guillaume un nouveau candidat le gars
était à fond sur la sur la sa
prétendante et il a essayé de trouver un
point commun entre eux et ça s'est joué
à un détail près regarde
là husky
j'en ai eu pendant onze ans je pense à
mon goût
[Musique]
fatal et ça m'a touché parce j'aime pas
me cacher j'ai eu comme t'y es tu vois
un petit carvalho et quand j'hésite
parce que tu as un husky et j'ai eu du
ski pendant 12 ans et paris ce qui sait
plus qui sam à la butte
[Applaudissements]
on voit qu'il ya peu une américaine
alors le pauvre pour guillaume il a
rencontré nelly une autre prétendante
qui était un peu flippante pendant la
dette tout le monde en a parlé sur les
réseaux regardez bien sa tête la meuf
c'est une espèce de gilles verdez
ofeminin pl à lecce l'on regarde ce que
je raconterai tout le monde quitte
qu'elle connaît à où la
belge est beaucoup beaucoup de copains
donc
on a un gros caractère tout ça
c'est à dire tous écoulés qui sont
partis donc je
voulais aller à nantes
[Musique]
oh
la défenseuse de boulbi elle sévit
depuis 15 ans
[Musique]
je la trouve plutôt mignonne mouais à la
quelque chose gilles tu regardes l'amour
est dans le pré de carole je regarde
chaque lundi soir régulièrement et je
vais même plus du tout comment comment
tu expliques tu sois le programme le
plus fort de la télévision actuellement
parce que on va dans les pires excès des
gens moi j'adore on va jusqu'au bout de
l'image dégradée des femmes
tout est faussé auxerre et laisse parler
la première ligne d'alun grady tube
ragga et mathieu suis pas d'accord du
tout parce que si tu es si mes fonctions
mathieu chef on sait peu sur je le
connais pas
encore en tout cas mais c'est absolument
pas dégradant même même la dame qui
chante qui chante pas très bien elles
sont très mal mais tu sens aussi bien tu
chantes mieux non dans son genre enfin
je sais pas vous dans la région que
voilà dans ses comptes les gens comme
ils sont dans la vie quand exactement
j'ai vu des gens comme ça car au kaki
qui faisait chante mal et c'est ce vaste
désert batik toilettes et j'ai moi je
trouve que l'émission c'est encore une
des seules émissions vrai atout c'est
vrai at il quand on voit thierry en
matière et qui s'endort là je sais tu es
chez toi ce matin là juste là la femme
juste avant moi qui dis oui mais
regardez il montre dans sa il fait sa
sieste etc enfin vous fait tous notre
pièce enfin moi je la fais c'est
guillaume au monde juste là la vraie vie
et sa jeunesse le jazz il bosse
ridha ben oui mais c'est ça c'est je te
dis moi je trouve l'émission la plus
vrai en ce moment à t c'est une des
seules émissions qui est encore vrai
tout ce qu'on voit ça y est c'est la
seule émission il se passe encore
quelque chose ah oui mais se fait chier
à télé lancement vraiment je vous dis
j'ai regardé tous les trucs cet été là
au moins il se passe un truc moi je
regarde l'amour est dans le pré je
rigole tu peux le prendre au premier
degré au dessus
voilà c'est sympa on est que l'émission
soit vrai c'est une chose mais moi ce
qui me gêne c'est que cette émission
elle est basée entièrement quasiment sur
le foutage de gueule en fait on est des
gens là bouvier pas que ces noms ne
s'est pas foutu là
dessus il est relativement moderne et à
la majorité des agriculteurs qui
participent il participe à l'émission au
premier degré et tout est fait notamment
au montage pour se [ __ ] de leur gueule
non quand il filme un break en train de
s'endormir quand il filme jean-yves
réduira au quai qui lui font dire qu'il
sait même pas ce que c'est qu'un karaoké
en 2022 ils font pas elle sait les
agriculteurs pour des gens arriérés
inculte et ce qui est très dur c'est que
comme on l'a dit ça fait beaucoup
d'audience et qu'il ya des vraies
conséquences dans la vraie vie et je
trouve ça véhicule une mauvaise image
des agriculteurs alors il a dû en noël
qui a fait beaucoup parler lui aussi sur
twitter ils étaient très contents de
rencontrer sa sa candidate elles sont
candidats regarder avec jean noël moi
j'ai suivi un pasa way qui suivirent
merci ben voyons on est beaucoup on est
beaucoup les autres il travaille pas
pour un sort du jour et joël bats toi
ans plus tôt est arrivé un truc oui
management
eh bien je suis allé dans un centre
dentaire pour me faire un détartrage
erreur de fini par faire d'une dent elle
resta tellement détartre équitable oui
c'est vrai la suisse est en fait avait
cherché un dentiste pour essayer de
réparer la chose dans la vie des filles
mais il ya un délai de 15 jours ce qui
fait que bas me voici avec une dent
manquante mais non j'essaie de sourire
de biais
alors on va en parler dans un instant
bien sûr vous savez on va en parler
qu'est ce qui se passe non mais je
trouve que guillaume hannezo on ne rit
pas avec eux mais au rythme énorme et le
français
c'est fou